for me it's been quite a journey this
last 12 years and and forgetting I've
and I started this 43 and what I the
metaphor I developed in the first couple
years when some of the same negative
stuff was popping up on my 360 every
year the metaphor is it's like being an
alcoholic that that when you're 40 and
you still have some of these behavioral
deficiencies and you've been a CEO for a
while
you got to recognize that it isn't just
someone gives you the feedback and you
have an epiphany and suddenly stop
acting that way just like an alcoholic
for the most part that I could tell you
I just decided to stop and it was easy
and and I'm never tempted and so so for
me on the part of the questions and a
number of these items I've literally had
to give myself a daily score then if I
waited for the next year I mean I'd be
I'd be better for two weeks after the
360 and then I'd slowly regress back to
my prior behavior pattern and then it'd
be ten months before my next week 60 and
then I'd be good for a month and and go
back so I I literally got to the point
where not only did I empower people to
sort of raise their hand when I was
doing the bad naughties but second every
every night I kept the spreadsheet with
the score to try to build my muscle
memory my ability to recognize when I
was going down the bad path so some I've
eliminated over the last seven eight
years and others I haven't the one on
getting angry with people and then to
perform actually the last two 360s were
the first ones where that was a minor
minor point and not totally gone but a
fraction of what it was before but it
took me eight eight years of having it
repeated in the old days another one was
micromanagement the big one that's still
in there was just two weeks ago is I my
ratio of positive to negative feedback
is not right that I'll give too much
negative feedback is relative to the
positive and I think about refilling
cups I'm excessively relentless and I
don't mean that in a in a good way
and so the two two big ones in there
today still are the relentlessness that
can just be draining for people and the
ratio of positive to negative feedback
the world